my beloved Yale family wherever you
might be I invite you to join me in the
spirit of prayer Almighty and loving
creator you are the force that lights
the Stars the architect of every cell
the source of all truth we look to you
as many expressions of one living
mystery a mystery beyond all telling in
this moment we are people grieving many
different types of losses and our hearts
beat with the rhythm of lament as we
cope with emotions too complex for any
of us to fully understand we who share
this beautiful but aching world we who
look at the same Sun in the same moon
are a people called to communal
restoration as students of your
handiwork we gathered at Yale from
throughout the earth with exquisite
ambitions and have been blessed at this
place of light and truth with the
freedom to let them grow our God of all
generations you are the guardian of
where we are going in who we are
becoming we are filled with gratitude
for our families friends teachers and
guides their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us and
today their hearts are holding fast to
us bless us as we seek to reimagine a
world made better by the considerable
gifts we will now bring to it
may we exude an intelligence that is
inspired by justice guided by tenderness
moved by holiness and always informed by
love as we greet tomorrow
steady us on solid ground and together
may we become vibrant living examples of
Shalom a Salaam
of Shanthi of peace for this we say Amen